February is home to one of the most important holidays of the year not to forget.
Groundhog Day.
If you live outside of Can-merica, then you might not know what a groundhog is, so...
...here you go.
This is a groundhog.
They're basically giant grumpy squirrels who dig burrows underground.
Burrows large enough in fact to occasionally make their comfy home...
...a structural hazard to your comfy home.
This explains the first half of their name.
The second half is because they're kind of fat.
Though unlike their fellow Can-mericans,...
...when winter arrives they need their excess weight to go into hibernation.
The story of the holiday is that on February 2nd...
...the wise groundhogs wake from hibernation to peek out of their burrow and look at the world.
If they see their shadow, they go back inside, which predicts six more weeks of winter.
If they don't, then spring will come early.
The holiday started in the 1800s as a Pennsylvania Dutch custom of weather prediction,...
...and today is celebrated in Canada and 49 of the 50 states.
The exception being Alaska, which in 2009...
...decided to forego Groundhog Day in favor of Marmot Day.